in Nogales on the Mexico side of the US
border a weary baby tries to steal some
sleep
her parents have set up camp desperately
hoping they're on the cusp of building a
new life in America they like Kenya are
trying to claim asylum she's pregnant
and she's just spent 15 perilous days
weaving her way here from Honduras with
her four-year-old son and Toby brendi
asleep ready at the removal ik is
amaryllis ready
embrace Rio alone in term of Peru and
see if a robber ami de la paura mia
capir Tavia taken on Dominica Comair she
said she had to escape her fearful her
son could be kidnapped by gangs at the
debate over the border rages that flow
of people hadn't stopped and small
patches of ground like this have become
symbols of life in transition and some
of these families will wait days before
they get their initial interviews with
US immigration authorities
[Music]
they are just meters away from Arizona
trying to cross legally something Donald
Trump's administration is trying to make
harder and getting through these
barriers is just the beginning
across the city there are families
huddled together waiting their turn
wrestling with their futures Dalila
spent 13 days on a long dangerous
journey with her three children home is
the poorest region at the most violent
state in the nation she tells me a
cartel killed her husband and she
believes she too was targeted she starts
to show me scars describing how the car
she was in was run off the road leaving
her without her liver and in a coma for
15 days she still won't risk crossing
illegally here though anyone who does
has a 30 foot fence to tackle a metal
curtain cutting through the hills
dividing two twin cities get caught and
you could end up here in a desert
Detention Center before you're thrust
into court or illegal immigrants arrived
by the busload under a fast-track
program known as Operation Streamline
convictions come thick and fast and
Judge Bernardo Velasco has a dizzying
workload I will see seven people with
seven lawyers standing in front of the
court in front of microphones the
process will take anything from 2 or 3
minutes to 10 or 15 minutes depending on
the judge there may be a conveyor belt
of cases in America but confusion reigns
over policy recently courts have
struggled to track down defendants
children who have been separated from
them we're great at enforcement
we're not so good at developing a good
immigration policy it's it's the front
half of this problem that we're not
solving so that's a little frustrating
2,000 children a yet to be reunited with
their parents hundreds are being held in
mist tent city in Tornillo taxes the
only images available of life inside are
provided by the government it is a vast
country and system to navigate a
casserole eaters shelter in Tucson
Arizona immigrants are getting legal
advice yeah I went but I think I get
they don't get anything
Timoteo says she is a victim of domestic
violence
sure death was the key a lot to me maybe
someone - knowing the causes can look
for por eso que toma la desicion this
epidemic on it under new rules
she won't automatically qualify for
asylum but she is driven by the dream of
her daughter
Rosemarie what would you like for your
life here in America if you can stay
and the master is the yeah America can't
decide on what and who it is willing to
accept what strikes you the most on this
stark frontier is that no one is
satisfied with the situation and still
by day and night the people come
Cordelia and Sky News Arizona